well guys it is that time of year again
it is time to talk about my picks for
the best films of 2013 I love doing this
this is like the one list each year that
I relish doing it's very difficult to I
always have a lot of trial and error the
fall in the winter really saved it this
year because up until then I was like
hmm
and as usual every time I make a list I
always mention that this is my list
there's gonna be things you may be like
where's that where's this Cris what are
you doing why is that there
I can't believe it it happens every year
people get up in arms about their
favorite film not being in a certain
position or whatever but this is my list
and what are you gonna do welcome to the
World Wide Web my friend also just like
last year there gonna be times real like
hey he gave that film an 8 plus and not
filming a - in that film in a so why the
order all weird because you should have
the a-pluses above that right there are
certain films that I think deserve that
great but there may be films that I did
enjoy more than that one based off of
whatever you know it's my personal
tastes and that's why this is my list
now before I get into my top 10 there
are some honorable mentions that I feel
must be discussed very briefly The
Hunger Games Catching Fire the
spectacular now Dallas buyers club
before midnight side effects this is the
end star trek into darkness the hobbit
the desolation of smaug and captain
phillips great great films I had a
really hard time not putting those in my
top 10 but there were 10 other films
that I enjoyed even more now starting
off at number 10 is an amazing
theatrical experience this is the kind
of movie that just sucked me right in
there I was in that world and for the
entire runtime of this movie I couldn't
take my eyes off of gravity this is a
movie with some of the best special
effects I have ever seen in my life 100%
realistic sometimes when you see a movie
that has really good CGI there's always
that one shot we can kind of tell well
yeah that's fake this movie does not
have that shot every shot in this film
completely sells the location of space
and Sandra Bullock and George Clooney
were great in the movie I really felt
that claustrophobia of her suit it was
just a non-stop thrill ride a very very
good movie coming into number 9 is a
film that some critics may have a little
bit higher up on their list I still
thought this was an excellent brutal
harrowing movie that just put you in
this space that you didn't want to be in
and
began to feel guilty to call herself a
human being 12 years a slave is an
extremely intense movie that is very
difficult to watch at times very violent
but at its core there's such a beautiful
human story of this guy struggle Steve
McQueen's Direction was great all the
cast was fantastic everyone in this
movie gave top-notch performances at the
core this movie despite all of the
horrible things you have to watch there
is this great story of human drama like
I mentioned and 12 years of slave is an
excellent movie at number 8 is a film
that hardly anyone saw barely anyone
ever talks about this movie ever it was
a foreign language film that did come
out in some other countries in previous
years but in 2013 the hunt came out in
the United States so for the United
States it is a 2013 film this movie
stars Mads Mikkelsen and he gives the
best performance I've ever seen from him
he plays a teacher who is falsely
accused of molesting a child by the
child this child decides to make up this
lie and it turns his life obviously into
a living hell and you get to see the way
people react when this type of thing is
spread through gossip and how that
gossip can affect a person's life in an
entire community when actually nothing
even happened the acting in the film is
tremendous Mads Mikkelsen is completely
oscar-worthy in this movie but it's the
type of film you watch and you just you
just want to punch these people in the
face these characters and the fact that
the movie can get under your skin that
much when these are actors portraying
fictional people that is something to
say I would strongly suggest seeing the
hunt if you haven't seen it it is not
easy film to watch is not by any means a
popcorn film but it is a very rewarding
experience and I hope you guys check it
out at number seven we have a film that
stars an actor who continues to turn his
career around who's impressing me
non-stop these days mud with Matthew
McConaughey I really adored this movie
and that's because the perspective of
the kid was so mature and there were
really surprising moments of action and
drama in this movie that just really
took me by surprise it was such a well
acted movie - on McConaughey's part the
kids part and Reese Witherspoon's part
as well nice to see her back in a good
movie I just remember being on the edge
of my seat towards the last few minutes
of this movie and it really impressed me
everything about this film I'm so happy
that Matthew McConaughey is doing good
stuff again if you didn't see mud when
it came out please check that one out at
number 6 we have a film that I
completely understood I mean everything
about this movie just hit me and I
completely got it it was like yes that
is exactly
how relationships are Don John Joseph
gordon-levitt's directorial debut really
impressed me I knew the guy was talented
I liked him in movies I think he's very
funny he does a lot of good stuff but
the fact that he wrote and directed this
movie and stars in it just shows the
amount of focus that he actually has in
regards to filmmaking the themes of this
movie where it shows how men can view
relationships from a very fantastical
aspect but women also can as well men
through pornography and women through
these very outlandish romance novels
that will never happen and I love the
way this movie was written and it was
also extremely funny Don John was pretty
frickin awesome
and number five we have one of my
favorite directors films and that is the
wolf of wallstreet starring Leonardo
DiCaprio directed by the one and only
Martin Scorsese this movie was just
hilarious I mean a non-stop laugh riot
as I said in my review scene the scene
to scene hilarity and it had such a
great way of getting you in the mind of
this lead character Jordan Belfort
played fantastically by Leonardo
DiCaprio Jonah Hill also gives the best
performance of his career here so much
of the dialogue was just so damn
entertaining at the entire film even
though it was three hours had me glued
to the screen the entire time and number
four we have the final film in the
unofficial Cornetto trilogy the world's
and directed by Edgar Wright starring
Simon Pegg Nick Frost this movie was
just a big ol geek time at the movies
sorry I just turn into Bill Cosby I
don't know why seriously though this was
a nerds wet dream this movie it was so
hilarious I love Shaun of the Dead
I loved Hot Fuzz the World's End just
might be my favorite one in that trilogy
the way that Edgar Wright direct is just
filled with energy and I love that about
his movies in the World's End was filled
with energy from shot to shot there was
never a dull moment in this movie I
found it extremely funny and also that's
a really cool action in it I mean the
bathroom scene everyone who saw this
movie remembers the bathroom scene I
wish that I could have gone to this
movie without knowing the actual plot
that eventually services because the
bathroom scene I remember my theater was
just erupting it was fantastic at number
3 we have a film that was also similar
to the World's End and that from scene
to scene to scene there was never a dull
moment in this movie this movie was
always turned on it never stopped
American hustle was a movie directed by
David or Russell with a fantastic
caste filled with great performances
that really captured its time and era
perfectly the soundtrack was so kick-ass
- and it was just really funny and
entertaining but it had a really great
script to it as well where you could
just watch these guys have dialogue and
you never got bored by dialogue because
each character was saying things that
were just so freakin interesting and I
know there was a lot of improvisation on
set - which says a lot for these actors
but the way David or Russell makes
movies is he tries not to create so much
of a plot where the film feels locked
down he likes to let his actors play a
little bit and that really shows in this
movie because every single one of these
actors just feels so free in their roles
and you can really tell because they're
giving performances where you don't see
the actor you just see these guys
characters American also was
entertaining from scene one it never
turned off I loved it at number two we
have a film that has stuck with me ever
since I saw it I've seen it again since
then on blu-ray it's the type of movie
that just leaves this feeling of
melancholy and dread at the same time
after it's over and I couldn't shake it
out of my system the place beyond the
pines is the type of movie like that now
I first saw this in 2012 at the Toronto
International Film Festival and I said
in my best of the Year video in 2012
that I would be talking about it this
year and I knew I would cuz it came out
in March of this year so it is
officially a 2013 release this movie
really dug into me I mean these
characters just came to life and it was
so shocking - I mean I won't spoil it
just in case you haven't seen it guys do
you have any idea how hard it was for me
to not tell you some of the things that
happened in this movie the first time I
saw it because when certain things
happen in this movie the audience you
could feel them just get low like
everyone in the theater was just like oh
my god that's so shocking because no one
expected certain things to happen in
this movie but it wasn't just the power
of seeing this for the first time
amongst a whole bunch of people who had
heard no buzz about it you know there
was no trailer for it there was no
promotional images or anything I just
went to this movie being like what's it
going to be about some a director of
Blue Valentine and it blew me away
definitely check out the place beyond
the pines it is a very different movie
extremely original I can't think of
another movie out there like it alright
guys the number one film of 2013 I have
sat through so many
this year some horrible some great but
there has been one film that has stuck
with me so deeply that I still remember
that feeling I had in the theater I
bought the blu-ray as soon as it came
out this film just hit me on every
correct level prisoners is my number one
film of the year this movie is a type of
movie that some people described as very
depressing type of film that some people
thought was not something they could
really watch again this film was made so
incredibly well and shot so phenomenally
well by Roger Deakins my favorite
cinematographer acted beautifully by
Hugh Jackman Jake Gyllenhaal Terrence
Howard Viola Davis Maria Bello Paul Dano
that the depressing aspect of it
actually didn't depress me I was just so
happy to watch someone who knew what the
hell they were doing making a movie
because you know I watch hundreds of
movies every year in the theaters and to
see one that just gets everything right
for me where each shot feels so
meticulously crafted to the end of time
like you can just tell these guys just
sat there setting up every little thing
before they shot it and the actors just
went over the roles over and over again
because they were so well prepared it
just felt like everyone was on their
perfect a game in this movie and yes as
I said it is a tough movie to watch it
is not a easy subject matter it's about
a family whose kids disappear and
another family whose kids disappear and
they're looking for them and they're
hunting for them and they're not sure
where they are there were aspects of
this film that reminded me of seven it
had that dreary quality to it but it was
beautiful at the same time because Roger
Deakins is a beast
do you member when people used to say
that like you're a beast like you're
really good at something so you're a
beast no one says that anymore but Roger
Deakins he's a beast behind the camera
prisoners is a movie that has stuck with
me ever since I saw it I was glued to
the screen completely transfixed for
every moment to this movie please check
it out if you have not seen it it is my
favorite film of 2013 so guys thank you
so much for watching my movie reviews
for another year it really honestly
means quite a bit to me that you guys
enjoy watching me chitchat about movies
because a lot of people are always like
you know Chris like you know what's up
with you man I'm just a guy who sits
down and talks about movies I don't
think highly and my
but the fact that anyone out there does
seriously means a lot to me I've gotten
so many fantastic messages this year
people saying that I've inspired them to
learn about movies or express themself
about film that just it makes my life
and you guys are freaking awesome and I
look forward to yet another year in 2014
watching movies with you guys that being
said my worst of the year pics will be
up very soon very different type of
video coming there guys as always thank
you so much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mint iced